okay we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P here's a really
good question about our colleague Luke
Beasley who has been going to Trump
rallies recently
hey dude I actually have a question for
you and a friend of the show Luke
Beasley yep um does he ever feel unsafe
at these rallies because
um you know you played that clip where
that guy was just cursing a lot at you
know Democrats and he said what have
these people ever done for Americans and
then Luke names a couple things tried to
get a few words in there and you know
when people are that unhinged I don't
try to talk sense into them and it's not
that I don't want Luke too I love it I
love his videos I love you know what he
sends you it's great
um I just wonder you know does he ever
feel unsafe yeah this is a fair question
and you know Luke is becoming more
recognizable because he's been going to
these rallies for a while so I I think I
I plan to have a conversation with Luke
to ask about that uh because we want the
number one priority is for Luke to be
safe and uh we we're certainly conscious
of that no doubt about it we have a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about Nancy Pelosi saying her
retirement will be affected by the
attack on her husband we will talk about
Facebook's plan to lay off thousands as
it is trouble in Paradise and we will
talk about Nike suspending its
relationship with Kyrie Irving over his
anti-semitic post all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad see it for yourself
don't take Alex Jones word for it sign
up at joinpakman.com